congrats on the movie I thought you guys
did such a great job especially because
I read that the movie was made in 31
days and I don't understand how you
pulled that off I don't really
understand it either so if you learn and
could tell us which is that Craig
Gillespie never stops he's a mad genius
and again and there's no cutting ever so
we rolled for 31 days straight that
actually yeah that sounds about right
actually you know um so one of the
things about this is like I left the
theater
um not I left the theater angry because
it reminded me of things and uh not in a
bad way like the movie's fantastic I was
just angry at um how how uh rigged the
system is yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah and so I wanted for both of
you what did you learn while researching
all this about hedge funds and Wall
Street that like sort of got under your
skin that you really just want to tell
people to remind them that the system's
yeah
I think first and foremost just how
opaque Wall Street is and how you know
it's it's designed to be hard to
understand you know we learned we we had
covered Finance for the Wall Street
journals reporters before we were
screenwriters but there were all kinds
of things we didn't know about like the
dtcc which is a body that like regulates
the whole stock market yeah it sounds
like a government Body by the way the
dtcc is a subsidiary of the nscc
people don't even own the stocks they
think they own actually the dtcc does
but you know that all sounds very wonky
the point being the system is not
transparent by Design and I think that's
part of what has led to so much anger
about the system being rigged and it's
on Wall Street it's also in Hollywood
you know we're here as producers of the
film but we're also writers of it and
part of the wga and very proud that our
Union is actually trying is fighting for
more transparency which is the only way
you know the only path back to fairness
we feel like whether it's in Hollywood
or on Wall Street yeah I could devote
this entire interview to transparency
from the streamers
yeah but Bob I'll actually ask you do
you think one of the things
do you think there's ever going to be
full transparency because I think that
the streamers are sort of hiding the
Hits and The like they don't want to
like they don't want to report anything
because then everything it's man there's
a big subject yeah I mean light light is
the best disinfectant right like when
the the why anytime someone is holding
information back and not sharing it
especially with the participants with
the people whose labor contributes to
that viewership you have to ask why what
why not share it what are you hiding
yeah again I could the entire interview
could be this but let me jump back into
the film yeah you obviously only have
two hours to tell the story and you're
basing you use the book as the you know
the the source material but how did you
decide what characters to focus on
because there could be so many people
that could be you know stories who could
be told so how did you decide where you
know what characters it was very hard I
mean it was very important to us to show
every side of the story to show the Wall
Street side the retail training side to
get into Robin Hood to get into you know
we had a GameStop employee who actually
brought us into the store played by
Anthony Ramos and it was also as we did
our own research and really talked to
people who invested in the stock and
were on Wall Street bets we were struck
by the tremendous you know diversity of
people who bought GameStop and were on
Reddit talking about it it was important
to us to really show the different kinds
of people who invested so we have you
know America ferreira's character who's
a nurse
um you know investing and we have the
Roaring kitties you know have more
financial experience we have the college
students we have the the GameStop
employee who became an investor in the
movement and and all of those character
portraits were drawn from interviews
that Lauren and I did in addition to
what we read in Ben's book we love Ben
and the book is great but we met so many
people and heard their personal stories
so not just looked at their balance
sheets and saw how much they won or lost
in terms of dollar figures but really
understood why as human beings they were
compelled to join this movement why they
were angry what they wanted and how
maybe they felt small before and how
joining this made them feel part of
something big and something important
and and that's what we were excited to
tell so we wanted to try to capture and
you're never going to do it perfectly
but we wanted to try to capture to the
best of our ability and with the limits
of time a good uh array of of experience
yeah so we had we wrote characters that
were actually cut from The Script but we
felt like one way of bringing in the
full movement was to have these Tick
Tock videos that are kind of you know
running through the movie as a chorus
that are real that we found in
researching the film and we had them in
the script as well that sort of show
other people in the movement and bring
in those voices there are obvious
comparisons here and we hear them all
the time to The Big Short Wolf of Wall
Street to kind of the cloud to The
Social Network the classic like finance
and and Technology movies but we also
looked a lot at Frank Capra and popular
the history of populist Cinema and tried
to kind of as grandiose as it sounds
create a new language of populist Cinema
for this generation and to us one way of
doing that I mean Capra was very
effective at elevating a reg regular
man's life into something worthy of the
big screen and one small way that we
tried to approach that was was
integrating at the script level real
tick tocks of real people who are part
of this movement so that when you watch
the movie you don't just see actors
playing characters who invested in
GameStop for one reason or another you
see real people dozens of them who
participated in this movement too yeah
and it felt radical to say like these
people deserve the big screen treatment
but it also felt really right for the
story to make them part of it one of the
things that I was wondering is because I
remember when all this was happening and
uh do you I wonder and I'm curious your
opinion do you think if the pandemic
hadn't been happening if retail if you
couldn't trade on your phone like it was
a convergence of all these different
things that made it so people were on
Reddit and paying attention do you know
what I mean well it took things that
have been happening in our world for a
long time right people being more
isolated feeling lonelier because of the
internet and social media it took you
know income inequality which has already
been a galling problem for a generation
or more and and ratcheted up times a
thousand so it was that the pandemic was
kind of fuel on the fire that brought
all these things together and created
the perfect storm right it was that
moment where like you would you would be
doing a zoom with your boss and your
boss was at home and you would see they
live in this huge mansion right people
really saw how you know who had stuff
and who did not for the first time we
tried to you know reproduce that yeah
you see it in the movie who's wearing a
mask and who isn't who's telling you to
put your mask on yeah um and who's like
grabbing a breath a entire firm you know
entire resort to move their firm down to
Florida Kevin Griffin yeah true story
who's stuck in their basement no a 100
but the other thing is I I uh while not
obviously some Savvy uh stock person I
had Robin Hood and it was after what
happened with GameStop that I ditched
that app because I was so angry by what
they did yeah well and that's back to
the transparency question right because
Robin Hood advertised themselves saying
like you know we have Commission free
trading and it's free but actually it's
not free and you know it's coming out
you know you the user is actually paying
for it in a hidden way a hundred percent
um uh talk a little bit about when for
both of you this is your first film what
is it like getting this cast in the
movie because obviously it's like this
All-Star lineup of people and they're
sort of like like have you thought about
playing the lottery recently like do you
know what I mean
it's our first produced film but we've
been working together as a writing
partnership for almost 11 years now um
so we've written a lot of movies and in
fact we've worked with Seth Rogen quite
a bit in the past although none of those
efforts ever reached this Craig
Gillespie this is our third outing with
Craig it's finally the one that got made
but we could like pay for the floor of
this room that did not get made that we
sold
um so we feel very lucky this is a movie
that got made and it's also I mean there
aren't that many movies like this
getting made in adult drama with comedy
like it's you know that we say that the
closest thing to a superhero kid in this
movie is the red headband that Keith
Gill wears and so it's a miracle that
this got made and in order for it to get
made everybody had to take a pay cut
this wasn't some big streamer movie
where everybody got a huge payday
everybody believed in the story we were
telling and they did it for a fraction
of what they normally know it was in
order to tell independently in New
Jersey with a big tax credit which is
how it got done well again like third
let's go back to the 31 days of shooting
like that that is not a movie that has a
lot of money like straight up like no I
mean all the money we didn't have a
video Village most days we would stand
behind Craig at the Monitor and
um yeah he'd been and again he shot the
whole time basically to get every minute
in there I'm curious with like roaring
Kitty right with something like this did
you actually get to talk to him and like
how does it work in terms of like his
life rights like and using the story did
um like you know what I mean one thing
that's great about Keith Gail I mean
there are so many things that are great
about Keith Gill is that he's a really
singular
um figure in that he's a reluctant hero
it feels like we live in a time where
everybody wants Fame and attention and
here is a person who really believes in
something and so brought his conviction
to the internet but didn't do it really
for the money or for the attention
because since then he has lived such a
private life
um so for us as screenwriters and as
just responsible like moral human beings
it was important to us that even though
he became a huge public figure and with
him his family became public figures to
a degree we wanted to both respect their
wish for privacy and also give them the
opportunities that we would want if we
were ever so lucky as to be in his
situation to to participate in the
process so we reached out to them
throughout the process and then we um we
you know drove to them and said we'll
show you the movie if you want we want
to respect their right for privacy so so
we won't go into that anymore but we
will say that they are the smartest
coolest fights
as extraordinary as he is yeah okay so
I'm just going to say that um I thought
that everything about because I'm from
the New England area I thought the
depiction of Brockton
um you know and all that was great my
only complaint about the entire film
it's very important
um so the movie takes place in Brockton
but you do not have anyone drinking
Dunkin Donuts as a matter of fact
machine Keith Gill on the subway his leg
is jiggling and he has a Dunkin Donuts
because I'm from Boston and I am
addicted to Duncan my mother got
hypnotized for her Duncan addiction so
this goes way back in my face and he
even he even I apologize yeah right I
missed the Duncan conduction but you
know what I feel like you're a real
Boston person if that was your you know
that's what you noticed but because
anytime a movie takes place in ball in
the New England area and and characters
are not drinking Duncan well it's not
real we'll tell you when we went to go
meet the Gill family we brought them
Dunkin Donuts by the way as you should
um so I'm curious with the editing room
I'm not sure how involved like were you
in the edit all the time with Craig but
how did the film possibly change in the
editing room in ways that you guys
didn't expect oh great question we had
an extraordinary editor on this movie
Kirk yeah who only does David Fincher's
films then made an exception for this
and it was such a complicated film to
edit because there's so much real
footage and
um that has to be kind of integrated in
but you know we said when we first
started writing we wanted the film to
move like a bat out of hell to quote the
great Billy friedkin we also wanted it
to feel like the experience of being on
social media so fast and choppy and
compulsive and energetic and where you
really get caught up in it
um and in order to do that it's not you
know seven minute scenes it's short
scenes and it seems where people who
never met each other and never in the
same room we have to show the way that
Community came together the way they
were bouncing off of each other getting
each other excited confronting each
other and so to do that you really need
a kind of like overlay of scenes so it's
one scene jamming into the next so the
edit is it is a lattice work it is a
masterpiece
every so often to see the cuts with Kirk
and Craig and the film will get shorter
and shorter and shorter but get great
news it's down to one hour 42 minutes
yeah to us one of the highest priorities
of this was that you you don't need to
know a single thing about the stock
market to totally get the movie and to
enjoy it so it was a I think one of the
surprising things was figuring out how
much to explain and how much to withhold
and I think we we aired on the side of
just not getting into it not bogging
down the movie with a complex
explanation of what call options are and
how they work so that you can really the
thing that matters most is the emotional
ride through this David and Goliath I
would also think trusting the audience
to understand like the basic mechanism
totally we showed the film you know we
did test screenings in Oklahoma City and
it was like the more we put in
explanations I think people then felt
bored or you know yeah and it actually
is better just to trust the audience to
go on the ride yeah I think there's a
lot of times movies water down
everything to to make it and then the
audience is smarter than you give them
credit for it yeah that's the whole
irony of dumb money right yes like that
these actually are smart investors who
are wearing this insult from Wall Street
as a badge of honor one of the things
though because I think I'm running out
of time time is what I think that the
movement and what happened fundamentally
changed Wall Street and like the dumb
money is no longer dumb I agree with you
you know and invisible people are no
longer invisible this is a community of
people millions of people that Wall
Street treated with scorn if they treat
it at all and now they will never be
ignored again and I'm sure Wall Street
will love to say like oh no we're back
to business that's not true but it was a
one-off there's apps now that like track
where retail investors are going to be
trading you know people at the big hedge
funds are looking at this they're
shorting less there's all kinds of
legacies from this and the story is not
over you know it's continuing GameStop
had earnings yesterday so we'll see what
happens well that's the thing though I
think that the short the shorting going
forward is is you can't do it because
people are too smart now yeah you know
what I mean yeah short positions have
have gone up and down since GameStop but
never reached the level pre-game stop
like people really people really learn
on Wall Street that a naked short word
sets you up for infinite losses and and
it's too risky to do anymore last thing
for you um do you think do you know what
you're gonna what's coming up next for
you guys in terms of producing or you
know we do we'll tell you one thing that
hasn't been reported yet which is we
um we have written a theatrical feature
film version of Murder She Wrote
um for a universal and we're really
excited so the Pascal pictures any
Pascal and Universal and we're very
excited to bring uh Angela you know well
Jessica Fletcher to the big screen yeah
yeah well I have so many follow-ups I'm
just going to ask you real fast uh let
me think about what my follow-up
question is going to be
um is it one of these projects that
Universal is gung-ho on in terms of like
have you already thought it started
talking about casting are you or is it
just the script just got basically they
seem pretty young how you wouldn't have
told you if they were we haven't talked
to them obviously in months but um
because it's a strange time but uh but I
think everyone feels like it's you know
it's Jessica Fletcher's moment to return
yeah I will leave it there and say I'm
very happy for the two of you and
sincere congratulations on this movie
thank you so much